al menos tres muertos dejó un ataque
ruso con morteros en la región de gersón
en el sur de Ucrania mientras las tropas
avanzan en sus esfuerzos por tomar
control de makmut en el este En medio de
enfrentamientos callejeros entre los
bandos la población civil que permanecía
en la asediada
china espera un crecimiento del 5% de su
economía este año y anuncia un
incremento del 7,2% de su presupuesto
militar el segundo más grande del mundo
en medio de crecientes tensiones con
Taiwán chilla aspira a la ratificación
de su tercer mandato en la cita anual de
la asamblea nacional popular
tras más de una década de discusiones
más de 100 países de Naciones Unidas se
acordaron en Nueva York un tratado para
conservar la biodiversidad en altamar el
pacto Busca proteger una tercera parte
del océano y de la tierra para finales
de esta década
Sean bienvenidos a este resumen
Informativo en France 24 los acompaña
Daniela Blandón comenzamos en Ucrania
donde una mujer y dos niños murieron
tras un bombardeo Ruso con morteros en
la aldea de ponía activa en la sureña
región de gerzona según la presidencia
de Ucrania Mientras tanto kiev dice
seguir repeliendo el asedio en la
localidad de backmuth a medida que las
fuerzas ucranianas las fuerzas rusas
intentan alcanzar su primera Gran
Victoria en seis meses que sería
estratégica para controlar más
territorios en la provincia de Don itzk
nuestra corresponsal Catalina Gómez
Ángel nos cuenta más detalles sobre la
evacuación de civiles en esta zona
en las últimas horas se ha conocido que
más y más personas que habitan la
población de bakú están buscando evacuar
la ciudad hasta la semana pasada las
autoridades de esta ciudad hablaban que
al menos cinco mil personas habían
decidido quedarse ellas vivían en
refugios subterráneos vivían sin
electricidad sin agua y de la ayuda
humanitaria que llegaba hasta allí
muchos se reunían durante el día en esos
puntos de invencibilidad donde les daban
comida les daban las medicinas que
necesitaban y también podían cargar sus
móviles es una ciudad que estaba
prácticamente incomunicada sin embargo
después del viernes cuando ya los
enfrentamientos se hicieron mayores y
los ucranianos decidieron destruir
algunos dos de los puentes que estaban
estratégicos en la ciudad especialmente
aquel que de la vía que conduce a
chasillar que era la única vía realmente
que daba acceso hacia un lugar seguro
mucha otra población decidió partir y se
conoce que los militares están
intentando ayudar a estas personas a
cruzar a través de un puente militar que
han creado en las últimas horas ellos
caminan hasta allí y ya allí cogen un
transporte que los lleva hasta un lugar
seguro pero también se ha conocido que
en el día de ayer una persona que
intentaba oír murió y dos quedaron
heridos y también algunas agencias que
han llegado hasta allí hablan de cómo
estas poblaciones aledañas o estas zonas
aledañas a este puente son atacadas
permanentemente según el ejército y
analistas militares dicen que la
situación en el frente continúa en el
Igual que ayer en mayor enfrentamientos
callejeros los rusos están atacando
hombre a hombre a las tropas ucranianas
que según una de esas organizaciones que
analiza la guerra dicen que estarían
planeando todo para retirarse hasta
ciertos sectores de batmut pero no para
abandonar la totalidad de la ciudad y
también se ha conocido que esas
poblaciones aledañas a bacmut que
todavía están en control de Ucrania y
que los rusos buscan controlar Para
encerrar la ciudad hay ataques allí ayer
hubo ataques en cada una de ellas pero
siguen en poder de Ucrania según ha
dicho el ejército de este país
y en otras noticias comenzó en Beijing
la versión número 14 de la asamblea
nacional Popular de china en la que se
espera la rectificación de Shin Pink
para un tercer mandato el Primer
Ministro saliente del iquique proyectó
un crecimiento económico del 5% para
2023 también anunció un alza del 7,2% en
el gasto militar para este año además
advirtió que el gobierno luchará contra
los intentos de independencia de Taiwán
nuestro corresponsal en Beijing Adrián
funcillas nos entregó más detalles china
Calcula que su economía crecerá
alrededor de un 5% el año que viene es
un objetivo realista y conservador
fácilmente alcanzable y que no requerirá
de las enormes y antiguas inversiones En
infraestructuras el dato lo ha revelado
esta mañana el Primer Ministro licán
durante la apertura de la asamblea
nacional popular con un discurso de
marcado carácter económico y es que esa
es la prioridad actual alcanzar la plena
recuperación económica después de tres
años muy complicados en los que se ha
juntado el coronavirus crisis en
sectores tan importantes como el
inmobiliario o la inestabilidad
internacional para conseguir esa
recuperación líquida ha prometido la
creación de 12 millones de empleos
urbanos y el estímulo del consumo
interno todavía muy castigado por la
pandemia el otro dato que se esperaba
con mucha expectación esta mañana era el
de el presupuesto militar crecerá un
7,2% apenas una décima por encima del
año pasado a pesar de que muchos
analistas pronosticaban una expansión
mayor debido a las cíclicas crisis con
Taiwán o la hostilidad creciente con
Estados Unidos Este ha sido el décimo y
último discurso de like frente a los
casi 3000 delegados del Gran palacio del
pueblo ha durado menos de una hora mucho
menos de las duraciones estándares aquí
en China será la despedida discreta de
un líder discreto que no siempre ha
estado en sintonía con el presidente y
que será sustituido a final de semana
por lichan un Aliado cercano de sí
y el Primer Ministro de Israel Benjamín
netanyahu rechazó la advertencia del
director general del organismo
internacional de energía atómica de que
cualquier ataque de Israel o de Estados
Unidos a las instalaciones nucleares de
Irán sería considerado ilegal Teherán
accedió a volver a conectar las cámaras
de vigilancia de varios centros
nucleares y también aumentar el ritmo de
las inspecciones para aclarar la
naturaleza de su programa nuclear
después de que el organismo de la ONU
asegurara haber detectado partículas de
uranio enriquecido a más del 80%, Irán
califica Este programa de inofensivo y
su histórico rival regional Israel lo
considera peligroso
tras volver de Teherán Rafael grossi
tiene cara de felicidad por una buena
razón Irán ha aceptado volver a conectar
las cámaras de vigilancia de varios
emplazamientos nucleares y aumentar el
ritmo de las inspecciones
los últimos meses ha habido una
reducción en algunas de las actividades
de vigilancia vigilancia adicional y
otras actividades en el área de
verificación que teníamos vinculadas a
las cámaras vinculadas a los mecanismos
de refuerzo en línea en términos de los
sistemas de monitoreo de flujo que no
estaban en operación por lo que hemos
llegado a un acuerdo para que vuelvan a
operar
operating social
el organismo Internacional de la energía
atómica había detectado recientemente
partículas de uranio enriquecido a más
del 83%, Mientras que el 90% es
necesario para fabricar una bomba
atómica Rafael grossi llegó el viernes y
se reunió con varios responsables
iraníes entre ellos el presidente
ebrahim Racing el objetivo era relanzar
las negociaciones estancadas
Hemos llegado a un acuerdo para definir
nuestra cooperación Y obtener garantías
como parte del histórico acuerdo de 2015
Irán limitó su enriquecimiento de uranio
al 20%. Esta visita Teherán es un primer
paso para reactivar el acuerdo que se
vino abajo en 2018 tras La retirada de
Estados Unidos en la presidencia de
Donald Trump
y un incendio masivo se registró en un
campamento de refugiados de la comunidad
musulmana rojinya en el sur de
bangladesh el cuerpo de bomberos local
reportó que la conflagración que tuvo
lugar en el distrito de Cox bazar Ya
está bajo control y no deja víctimas por
el momento según Naciones Unidas más de
un millón de refugiados rojin ya han
migrado a bangladesh desde myanmar
durante décadas huyendo de la represión
militar contra esta minoría ética
ya una semana de que Italia se viera
sacudida por una nueva tragedia acerca
de la costa de calabria el Papa
Francisco urgió a las autoridades a que
tomen mayores acciones para detener a
los traficantes de personas en el mar
Mediterráneo el domingo pasado murieron
más de 60 personas y las autoridades
estiman que la cifra de víctimas podría
haber llegado a 100 este drama ha vuelto
a llamar la atención sobre la política
migratoria italiana ya que se produce
apenas cuatro días después de que se
aprobara un nuevo código de conducta
para los barcos de rescate de migrantes
unos últimos preparativos antes de
partir este equipo humanitario está a
punto de salir hacia la parte central
del Mediterráneo Este es el Ocean viking
un barco fletado por la ong sos
mediterráneo para prestar asistencia a
las embarcaciones de migrantes que huyen
de África con la esperanza de llegar a
Europa
durante nuestras misiones vemos
embarcaciones que no están en
condiciones de emprender un viaje Así
cuando los encontramos algunos se han
quedado combustible o están perdidos en
el mar esta vez el barco se verá
obligado a respetar la nueva ley
aprobada recientemente por el gobierno
italiano en materia de operaciones de
salvamento marítimo ahora está prohibido
realizar rescates múltiples aunque esta
ong tenga capacidad para salvar varias
embarcaciones de migrantes en peligro de
naufragio y apenas en cuanto Terminamos
el primer rescate nos dan un puerto para
desembarcar y nos dicen que navegamos
hacia él a la máxima velocidad eso va en
contra del derecho internacional que
estipula que si un capitán está en
condiciones de ayudar a un barco en
dificultades debe hacerlo debe
intervenir este barco fletado por
médicos Sin fronteras es el primero
sancionado por la nueva ley las
autoridades italianas les acusan de no
facilitar información suficiente sobre
su último rescate marítimo el resultado
una multa de hasta 10.000 euros y la
movilización del barco durante 20 días
aquí en el puerto de augusta en sicilia
se recibe la noticia con mucha
frustración y con Pues con mucha
preocupación pensando sobre todo en las
personas que podríamos
asistir y que bueno pues por desgracia
no va a poder ser hay una intención
Clara de mantener a los barcos de
rescate lejos de la zona de operaciones
mientras esperan a que finalice el
periodo de restricción el equipo prepare
el material para la próxima misión en la
ruta de migrantes más mortífera del
mundo en los últimos 10 años casi 25.000
personas han perecido intentando cruzar
el Mediterráneo
y de Italia vamos a Grecia en donde
nuevas protestas multitudinarias tienen
lugar por el choque de trenes que mató
al menos a 57 personas en la noche del
pasado martes el Primer Ministro griego
kiriaco mitsutakis pidió perdón a los
familiares de las víctimas este domingo
se rindieron homenajes en la estación de
larisa en donde ocurrió la tragedia más
temprano hubo choques entre
manifestantes y la policía en Atenas
después de que más de siete mil
quinientas personas se congregaran
frente al parlamento para seguir
expresando su rabia tras el accidente
ferroviario más mortífero en la historia
reciente del país
hoy es domingo de elecciones generales
en Estonia los comicios se enfrentan al
gobernante partido del centro derecha de
la primera ministra caja callas una de
los gobiernos europeos son más cercanos
a kiev contra un partido de extrema
derecha que busca capitalizar la ira por
el aumento del costo de vida y que ha
abogado por limitar la admisión de
nuevos refugiados ucranianos más de
900.000 estonios están habilitados para
renovar el parlamento de 101 escaños
aunque casi la mitad ya lo hizo a través
del voto electrónico
tras más de una década de trabajos
preparatorios y de negociaciones
Internacionales los países de la ONU
alcanzaron un acuerdo para la protección
de alta mar que ya ha sido tildado de
histórico se trata del primer tratado
internacional cuyo objetivo será la
protección de un 30% de los océanos para
2030 un acuerdo destinado a
contrarrestar las amenazas que pesan en
el ecosistemas vitales para la humanidad
de ambos una larga noche después de dos
intensas semanas de discusiones los
estados miembros de la ONU firmaron el
primer tratado internacional para
proteger la alta
damas y caballeros
el barco ha llegado a la orilla
valió la pena la espera los activistas
han elogiado el histórico tratado como
un logro trascendental ya que permitirá
la creación de áreas marinas protegidas
en estas aguas Internacionales La
altamar comprende alrededor de dos
tercios en los océanos el mundo y casi
la mitad de la superficie del planeta
dado que se extiende hasta 200 millas
náuticas es en las costas todos los
países pueden usarla para pescar Navegar
y realizar investigaciones pero hasta
ahora solo el 1% de estas aguas han sido
protegidas lo que significa que la vida
Marina en altamar se enfrenta amenazas
como la sobrepesca el tráfico marítimo y
el cambio climático su redacción exacta
aún no ha sido acordada pero el tratado
requerirá que los países realicen
estudios e impacto ambiental de las
actividades propuestas en las aguas
ayudar a proteger los preciosos
ecosistemas del océano que producen la
mitad del oxígeno que respiramos los
humanos y limitan el calentamiento
global al absorber el dióxido de carbono
antes de que se adopte formalmente el
acuerdo deberá ser examinado por
abogados y traducido a los seis idiomas
de la ONU y cerramos con noticias
deportivas el líder de la liga francesa
al psg celebró por todo lo alto La
hazaña de su estrella kilian mbappé
quien el sábado se convirtió en el
máximo goleador histórico del equipo
mbappé anotó el último tanto en la
goleada del psg sobre el nantes que
extendió a 11 puntos su liderato al
frente de la liga y de esta forma rompió
el empate que mantenía con el uruguayo
Edison cavani en una ceremonia al final
del partido celebrado en el parque de
Los Príncipes mbappé recibió un trofeo
con el número 201 la cifra de goles a la
que llegó
de esta manera llegamos al final de las
noticias quédense con nosotros
[Música]